turning now to the fight against the
coronavirus Nationwide the number of new
cases has dropped to an average of
around 45 000 a day a level we have not
seen since July of last year so far just
over 69 percent of the eligible
population has been fully vaccinated the
Pfizer shot is the most popular with
more than 123 million of those fully
vaccinated people getting that type of
vaccine Pfizer's chairman and CEO that's
Dr Albert borla has a new book it's
called moonshot inside Pfizer's
nine-month race to make the impossible
possible and yes they did that it
provides an inside look advisors push to
develop a coveted vaccine we're very
happy to tell you that Dr borla joins us
on the table it's so nice to see you in
person and to have you at the table
thank you for having me you know when I
was reading the book and I was thinking
about the title nine months is how long
it takes to have a baby too by the way
Dr borla so I thought ah there's
something there but when you say that
yes yes that too when you say you pushed
your team hard and you you admit that
you pushed your team hard you also said
that sometimes you don't regret being
pushy but you regret being unnecessarily
unpleasant you said so when you say you
push the team how hard did you push what
did you ask of them
I asked them to make the impossible
possible basically and uh in numbers
what does that look like when we when we
do a development of a vaccine usually
takes 10 years I didn't ask them to do
it in eight years if they would if I
would they would try to find Solutions
within the Box yeah to perfect the
current process I asked him instead of
eight years to do it in eight months
eight months yearly fires are
manufactures 200 million doses of all
vaccines across all manufacturing sites
in the world before the pandemic I
didn't ask them to make 300 of the
coronavirus ask them to make three
billion when you ask something that it
is so out of what is the Comfort level
of everyone they have to think
completely outside outside of the box
and you will be surprised how much they
will deliver yeah but you know you sound
a little crazy asking something because
that does seem impossible but your team
delivered and along with that there were
concerns well they must have cut Corners
this can't be safe as you point out in
the book we still don't even have a
vaccine for the HIV so and you know how
long that's been going on so the big
concern was well they must have cut
Corners yes and that was always what was
the guiding principle we will never cut
corners and not only us but the entire
industry made the pledge to speak about
it and we did that by making things in
parallel rather than sequencing yeah
they did it in parallel instead of
sequential and also we did that at risk
we didn't wait to start manufacturing
after we know we have a vaccine because
otherwise could cost a lot of money we
started manufacturing without even
knowing which vaccine we are going to
manufacture we were starting with all
potential candidates and as we were
dropping candidates to go to the one
that eventually was selected
manufacturing was dropping quantities
that they made of the other ones now
speaking of those vaccines Dr parents of
kids under five are still waiting for
that vaccine and I know that Pfizer
pushed back the timeline for requesting
the FDA authorization when can parents
expect that vaccine to be available I
believe next month we will know the data
and I think if then FDA will move very
fast
well now they've said that we don't need
to wear our mask anymore that you know
do you really I feel we've said this so
many times Albert borla that the end is
near we've seen a light at the end of
the tunnel and then something comes up
and knocks us off again but now they're
saying the end is near take down your
mass do you feel comfortable with that
you do you think that's okay I do think
that anyway it is something that Society
is tired so I think we need to move to
more realistic measures but also we can
because not only we have vaccines but
now we have treatments President Biden
announced a major initiative the test
and treat that's if goes well people
will be able the moment that they get
some symptoms to get the treatment which
appeals and then 90 of them will not go
to hospital so it's amazing I really go
ahead you write a lot about equity and
you talk about getting the vaccine to
people around the world and I have to
mention this um you know your company
made more than 22 billion dollars last
year why not just give the vaccine away
to people in need to in this pandemic I
think we do so from the from the get-go
we set the price for the high income
countries but the low-income countries
they were getting the vaccine at cost
and in fact we did an agreement with the
U.S government and the U.S government
both a billion doses from us they bought
it at Cost so we're not losing money
we're not making money but then the U.S
government is donating those doses the
problem right now in Africa and other
places where they have low vaccinations
yeah it is that they have problems of
infrastructure not of vaccine
availability anymore we need to invest
in educating them you need to invest in
vaccination centers this is what needs
to be done now yeah and you talk about
there's a great story we don't have time
to get into it when you found out the
efficacy of the vaccine you gather
everybody on a Sunday morning and you
guys would have been happy with 50 to 70
percent effective and it was
95.6
95.6 all right I'm a Pfizer girl just
saying I'm not just saying that because
you're here and you call the book
moonshot
because because it was a very long
Visionary Target that could have
significant consequences in everything
else that happened it's not only that we
develop a vaccine I think the technology
has matured so much during this time to
develop a vaccine that pretty soon
cancer or other diseases will see the
benefits of the MRNA technology let's
hope Albert borla we are ready for the
next thing let's we're all asking that
because there will be a next thing we
thank you very much thank you so much
for coming to the table so much Nate
it's called moonshot it's on sale
tomorrow wherever you like to buy your
book